hello everyone welcome
it is september 13 2022.
we're here at the active inference
institute with john vervicky so john
welcome thank you for joining
i'm very much looking forward to this
conversation
hello and to you
thank you daniel it's a great pleasure
being here i'm looking forward to this
is there any introduction or hello that
you'd like to provide as we
head into this journey together
i guess i can give just a little bit of
background so people know where i'm
coming from i'm an associate professor
at the university of toronto
i'm i'm appointed both in cognitive
psychology
and in cognitive science i teach in both
and i am the director of the cognitive
science program uh so i do a lot of work
integrating especially psychology and
um ideas from artificial intelligence
large framework models philosophical
framework models for the nature of the
mind i especially do work on
intelligence consciousness insight
flow mindfulness and wisdom
all centered upon a notion uh uh
well not a notion a proposal a
theoretical proposal that i call
relevance realization and perhaps we'll
get into that at some point
into it we go
so to provide some context
these live streams are
multi-directional roads
we're going to be talking about
different ideas for some people it'll be
their day-to-day life and the water they
swim in for other people it might be
their first time hearing about relevance
realization or predictive processing or
active inference
and so we always want to make it
accessible and also provide depth
so
yesterday in speaking with some
other participants at the institute
about how to frame this discussion
i was bringing a notion of a
three-legged stool
and the three legs of this stool
that provided stability are again those
relevance realization predictive
processing and active inference
and then a participant dean said flip
the stool it's still stable
and so that led to some discussions of
what was
the betweenness of these ideas and what
were they really doing alone and what do
they do together
and we're going to approach that
so
first we'll be exploring relevance
realization and predictive processing
in terms of what they are and how you
recently connected them in a recent
paper and then we'll bring in active
inference as a third guest to the party
but first
what is relevance realization and what
is predictive processing
how did you bring those two together in
the recent work with brett anderson and
mark miller
so the two lines were
uh working independently
um
i first got my first paper officially
accepted in 2009 didn't get published
until 2012 because they were holding it
back for a special issue that took
forever to come out uh the reason i
mentioned the earlier date is that's
before i think most of fristen's major
publications um and that's just and i'm
not claiming precedent or anything i'm
just claiming independence i didn't know
about his work until after the theory uh
was well developed and i assume he might
even not know of mine even now and
that's fine um
uh so the idea behind relevance
realization is that if you take a look
at many different problems
uh within attempts to explain the mind
in a non-homuncular
non-question begging manner you hit this
problem of relevance realization
so for example
how does categorization work well we
notice the two things are similar what
does it mean to say they're similar
well logically it means they share
many properties and then goodman
famously pointed out that any two
objects share an indefinite number
of true properties
you know
a plum and a lawnmower both have rounds
shiny surfaces they're both found in
north america neither one existed 300
million years ago both have an odor
neither one is a particularly good
weapon etc etc etc and what people will
say to me is they can't say those are
false because they're all true they'll
say but that doesn't matter and that's
the move
right when you go from logical
similarity to psychological similarity
you say well i zero in on
the relevant
comparisons
ah and how do you do that and that of
course is still the crux
of the categorization problem let's take
a look at inference well
well inferences just to follow all the
implications of a proposition in
relation to other propositions well how
many are those
well let's take a proposition it's it's
going to be windy tomorrow that has you
know that would have implications for me
if i'm sailing uh that are different for
the implications for me if i'm flying a
kite or if i'm planning to have a picnic
or i'm planning to stay inside or if i'm
planning to take an airplane
and do i check out all the possible
connections between that proposition
um no i only select those that are
relevant and this was a point made very
very well quite a while ago by
christopher christopher cherniak in his
book
uh minimal rationality
problem solving i i many of you are
already familiar with this so i'll just
state it we know that the search space
for most problems is combinatorially
explosive you can't search the whole
space so you have to somehow ignore most
of the space while nevertheless reliably
being able to solve a wide variety of
problems in a wide variety of domains
i can make similar arguments for
communication i can make similar
arguments for learning etc i won't go
into them i'm just giving enough to
exemplify that yeah independently all of
these things keep crashing into this
issue of zeroing in on the relevant
information
and you can even note it uh at it you
know in your everyday experience what
should you pay attention to right now
what should you draw from working memory
what should you draw from long-term
memory um especially with the fact that
you can combine different things from
long-term memory what sequence of
actions should you perform what
possibilities you could consider etc
i take it that this
is at least plausible enough for me to
go on people can take a look at
all the publications to see the
arguments more in depth so this crucial
ability for relevance realization uh
needs to be addressed if we're ever
going to provide i i've argued i've
argued since my thesis that if we're
going to provide a naturalistic
explanation of the mind and does it read
to which we avoid it try to just pretend
it's not there etc
i think it undermines our efforts to
give a naturalistic explanation now this
is sometimes called the frame problem
i don't call it that anymore because
shanahan has rightly argued that the
frame problem was two separate problems
uh one was to create a viable logic for
change
uh that didn't get you sort of enmeshed
in a bleed out of all kind of identities
and he argues that that
challenging problem has largely
been solved he claims to be one of the
people that solved it nobody seems to be
challenging him on that i i i don't
either
what he says remains and those are his
words not mine is the deeper problem of
relevance that's exactly what he calls
it the relevance problem um so
this problem is a key problem and
i have a proposal that i've worked on
with other people
tim littlecraft blake richards leo
ferraro
brett anderson and mark miller in the
recent paper uh gary hovinesian in a
paper we recently published um also
integrating relevance realization theory
and an active big five personality
theory
uh and the proposal
i mean the
proposal has more sort of technical
details but just to give the idea um
and we're not claiming that this i'm not
claiming none of us claim that this
proposal is completely
novel what we're claiming is you see it
implicit in many different areas where
progress is being made and you can draw
it out and explicate it and therefore
make more specific proposals of how to
look for it or how to engineer it
and this is the proposal that
the brain basically uses at many
different levels opponent processing uh
and what it's doing is it's doing
something very analogous to evolution
it's opening up uh variations and then
putting selective pressure on them and
then from that opening up variations
putting selective pressure
uh on them and you you can see this at
many different levels your attention is
doing it right now
uh your default mode network is trying
to make your attention wander off and
introduce
new ideas
your task focuses network is drawing it
back in killing off most of those
options but one of two that might be
actually relevant to
what's going on you keep them
and the idea is that you do this and
there's many of these trade-off
relationships i'm just giving one
example there's many of these trade-off
relationships they're operating
in a massively recursive
multi-dimensional uh self-organizing
process to help you repeatedly zero in
on the relevant information like i say
there's more detail uh
obviously
uh but that's as as fast as i could make
it uh a gist of what uh the theory
is uh is
proposing
thank you for the summary definitely a
lot there
in
one way it's like moving from the sketch
of the continents and the lay of the
land the space of the possible for
cognitive science across these different
domains
and then asking how the relevant
view combinations are selected and then
one can point to a broad range of
so-called cognitive phenomena
in human as well as in other cognitive
systems
learning memory planning attention
compositionality action selection and
policy inference
all of these areas
which one might imagine could have
bespoke custom theory
or there might be a way to look at some
similarities
ironically or not finding the relevant
similarities in these different
cognitive domains and asking whether we
could improve our inference and our
action regarding those domains through
the usage of an integrative framework
like relevance realization
that's excellent daniel and so just to
add to why i think it's uh reasonable
and perhaps even plausible that there is
such a domain general central capacity
is we have uh robustly replicated
evidence uh for uh the existence of
general intelligence by the way general
intelligence doesn't mean it can't be
analyzed in components it means at its
functional level it forms a causal whole
that has you know reliable predictive
relations and we have it's you know it's
the most powerful psychometric in
psychology and people don't like to hear
that but it is nevertheless the case um
we and so we have evidence that there is
above all and not in not in place of but
above all the specific learning you have
for specific domains there is
powerful evidence for general
intelligence a domain general ability
the way we test for it leo and i made
this argument in another paper is
basically we test for people's capacity
at relevance realization again and again
and again um and so
um that's why i think it's plausible
that there is this underlying
uh
capacity
and
what what that helps do is it helps it
it allows you
it allows us to bridge into more
comprehensive patterns of explanation we
have
so for example
the model i just proposed to you um is
explicitly
an analogy but a strong analogy you know
to the way evolutionary processes
produce adaptive morphology for market
organisms um
evolution variation selection and the
pro and it doesn't require an
intelligent designer right evolution is
clearly a process that is itself not
intelligent and can produce intelligence
and so that gives us uh the potential
way out of any homuncular explanations
of intelligence uh like you know the
central executive selects this or that
and those kinds of explanations that
just presuppose an answer to this
question and so instead the idea is no
no um
the brain
at this general level again i'm not
denying specific heuristics although i'm
proposing that perhaps relevance
realization is how those specific
heuristics might be generated i'm not
i'm not denying specific heuristics i'm
not denying domain specific knowledge
i'm not denying any of that but i'm
saying there is a general ability
just like there is right this general
process of evolution for biological
adaptivity there is this general if
you'll allow me cognitive evolution of
your fittedness your cognitive
fittedness as a problem solver
to your environment
yes in in those ways it's very resonant
with
generalized uh darwinian models or like
neural darwinism as well as the
trend in
eco evo devo ecology evolution and
development
by way of looking at proliferation and
that pruning back process
in different spatial and temporal scales
different systems like the way that it
might happen with synapses forming and
then being pruned during development the
way that ecosystem assembly might occur
with initial
plants forming some sort of substrate
that later forms a ground for
development and then even at slower and
longer time scales with evolution and
especially when we think about the
neural aspects learning and behavior are
part of development they're processes
that happen within a lifetime
and
that is a great
angle to consider so
relevance realization in our
first pocket let's move to the second
leg
predictive processing what is predictive
processing and how did it come into play
and why did it come into play for this
recent work
so i've been familiar with predictive
processing um and i would often be an
annoyance at the conferences where
predictive processing uh was being
presented because i would ask where does
the model come from and uh where's the
innovations for the model come from and
uh things like that um
because uh i was i
and and the questions were genuine i
wasn't you know i wasn't trying to
sabotage i wanted to understand uh how
this was
um
integrating and i wasn't getting to be
fair and you know and the fault is
probably also mine you know i mean i i
was
i was learning all about this i've
learned about it quite a bit and you
know and i have my bias uh but brett
brett anderson approached me and he said
look
um
i think that what you're doing in
relevance realization is really needed
for predictive processing
and then at the very same time almo and
this is one of those uh happy
coincidences that are the shadows of god
or something like that uh a former
student of mine who went through the
cognitive science program with me mark
miller who has worked with andy clark
and a bunch of the other uh predictive
processing people
came and he said john i i want to start
working with you again and i want to
integrate what you've been doing and
i've been doing and so
the three of us started talking
and and um
and
you know when we went back and forth a
lot and we came up with
um a way in which we saw these two
theories converging so predictive
processing i mean there's a lot of
technicalities and people vary to the
degree to which
uh they're committed to
you know a strong bayesian or a weaker
bayesium everybody agrees that you can't
be pure based because it would be
computationally intractable you have to
do some approximation and then the idea
is you have a massively recursive
um
network that is basically
um doing something really in in
interesting
now again not to claim priority or pres
precedence but independently
in the 2012 paper uh we predicted that
the brain basically
uh tries to model itself in order to
model the environment uh because this
actually gets you uh
through a lot uh past a lot of difficult
problems
um and that was uh and independently and
again like uh i want to give dude credit
uh the idea was no no the brain
shouldn't predict the world uh the brain
should predict itself in a multiply
recursive self-correcting fashion in
order to predict the world and for
reasons that i won't go into right now
that just that that just
gets you past so many of these
roadblocks right and then the idea is
well what should the brain what is the
brain doing when it's predicting itself
you know
there's all kinds of math but up you
know a good interpretation is the brain
is trying to reduce the degree to which
it surprises itself the brain is higher
levels well all right you've got a level
of the brain the level is meant to be
taken as an abstraction not an
anatomical region there's a level of the
brain that is you know doing the sensory
motor interaction with the world and the
idea is this is a loop it's not input
output it's a continuous loop where
sensation perception is modifying action
and action is modifying uh perception
and so there's a there's a level of the
brain that is just registering that as
patterns of activity in that causal
interaction and then layers above it try
to predict
how that pattern's going to unfold and
when there's error the error is fed back
into that layer and it is corrected to
try and make a better prediction and
then what you do is you do this
massively recursively you have layers
predicting the layers below them so on
and you propagate error up and you
propagate prediction down
and what that does is it um
it allows you to slowly slowly hone in
on the causal structure of the world and
it doesn't promise to get you the
perfect causal structure of the world or
any cartesian thing like that
but
what's really interesting and one of the
things we talked about is you know you
also have that recursive sort of
stacking of layers of prediction in
various models of deep learning
and deep learning also does right it was
one of the inspirations for relevance
realization theory it does the variation
and selection you know in in things like
the wake sleep algorithm right and we
thought hey there's a lot of things
converging here
and then you know we
started examining this with other people
like clark you know and we're going
through it he says well you know what uh
what do you predict you can't there's
there's a combinatorial explosive number
of patterns you could predict in the
environment well then you you know you
you predict the important ones or the
relevant ones oops that's going to be
problematic and then they try to you
predict the reliable ones now that's not
good yet enough and then you had the
idea of precision weighting in which
you're you're trying to prioritize uh
which patterns are given processing
which is
basically a model and many people
explicitly claim this in the predictive
processing uh framework of attention
that's what attention is attention is
psychologically a prioritization process
that's doing the precision weighting
that make that helps the
the predictive processing avoid
uh a combinatorial explosion you can see
the convergence coming in here
uh but then you know and
fairly recently i think it was 2017 2018
clark was talking about this and he said
well precision waving als ultimately
comes down to task relevance and we and
you know and
it was like oh no right that's just
homuncular uh we we need a little man in
there just that's relevant that's not
relevant um and that can't be it and
then what you see is
uh predict the predictive processing
framework is moving to trying to come up
with sort of uh dynamical
self-correcting
way in which the trade-off relationships
in the environment are being used in
order to help
trade-off relationships sorry in the way
the organism is trying to
survive in its environment that's more
accurate
um can be made use of in an opponent
processing fashion to help
right get a non-homuncular account of
the precision weighting and we saw the
two theories as ja oh wow they're
converging they're coming right together
and then it looks like they could
actually help each other the relevance
realization can help you know explicate
what these trade-offs are like and the
kind of opponent processing make and i
do mean explicate i think this is
already implicit in the most cutting
edge work within precision weighting and
predictive processing uh and and the
predictive processing i sometimes like
to use this analogy and don't push it
too far but i think the predictive
processing is basically giving us the
mendelian genetics of intelligence
and relevance realization is giving us
the darwinian evolutionary theory and
they need each other very deeply and
there's a lot of things that the
relevance realization theory can give to
the predictive processing that it
doesn't do
as directly on its own
these are things like
helping to explain connections to
a lot of phenomenological features
salience
increase the uh
the linkage to theories of consciousness
i can go into all of this in detail and
so um the two theories just came
together
and they really strongly support each
other i think a very strong advantage
which is coming out now
and this is something
we're just starting to work on so i
don't have too much to say that i'm very
confident about but
i i'm confident in the intuition that i
will have something to say which is that
you know there's been a very strong
critique of the predictive processing
framework coming out of somebody who i
hold in very high regard evan thompson
um and
and it's complex
and there's an ongoing debate i do think
that um
evan's
main point if i can boil down a very
complex argument i hope evan will
forgive me because i'm just trying to
make sort of a promise here but make it
a plausible promise
is that um the predictive processing
can be sort of refuted with you know
easy counter examples of you know
pendulum clocks in training on a mantle
piece and all kinds of so you get you
get panned psychists from all over the
place uh if predicted pro of these
predictive processes are supposed to be
the model of the cognitive i've heard
some predictive processing people just
bite that bullet uh but for me uh
that seems implausible i think the
answer
which is
almost
uh
forefronted in some ways in evan's point
is that predictive processing is not
really as 4e as it claims to be it's not
properly embodied embedded and active
and extended
now i think
the way
out of that is by
the connection the integration uh with
relevance realization theory because
relevance realization theory um
rounds out in the bioeconomy of an
organism
and it grounds out in
the fact
that relevance is always relevant to
a system that is auto poetic
montague put it very well we're
different from computers in that they
don't care about the information they
process we care about the information we
process and i propose to you we care
about the information we process because
we are fundamentally taking care of
ourselves we are autopoetic beings and
the theory of relevance realization
ultimately grounds out it says that
relevance is deeper than representation
it's deeper than inference it's deeper
than logic it's actually running off the
bioeconomics of the organism and it is
working in terms of the autopoiesis and
so i think if predictive processing is
integrated with relevance realization it
gets very clearly and explicitly and
deeply integrated with involved
continue
with embodiment and embeddedness and
that would address i think many of the
criticisms that are
emerging from from evan thompson's uh
critique uh so that's that's a
so not only is there increased
explanatory power outward in terms of
explaining fundamental phenomena there's
ex
there's increased explanatory power in
responding to deep criticism so that's
sort of
where we're at right now
amazing many ways to
go here and many great questions in live
chat that i know we'll be able to get to
one
footnote that we'll come to as well is
connecting so many of the terms that
we're using here
which are being used in a technical
sense scientific or even formal and
mathematical to their everyday uses
ranging from
attention and relevance to all these
different notions of prediction
explanation
design control
and so forth so connecting these natural
language terms to the way that they're
used in cognitive sciences is a very
rich area
for the predictive processing
architecture itself
you absolutely conveyed it which is it
is building from bayesian formalisms
around inference
and uses a vertical nested model
spatial metaphor it's not actually like
a skyscraper or anything like that where
higher levels are making ongoing
predictions and lower levels are said to
be feeding upwards
observations and initially or at the
most peripheral aspects of the agents we
have what are most sensory-like
observations but those can become
processed in a predictive framework
step by step for example edge detection
and vision object recognition and so on
um
and then
very interesting how um
even at the very beginning
asking how this came about
you spoke to the way that brett and mark
became involved in this ongoing line of
research which i think speaks to the
social inaction of research and the
distributed cognitive elements of
development of theory and practice
and then to bring to the very end
that the relevance is agentic and
situational
and that's kind of like the strange loop
or like the
quasi-tautology like fitness
in an evolutionary setting is
situational
and it is both the most mysterious
and explanatory phenomena and it's the
most circular
phenomena and so relevance as well is so
hyper situational
that
it can seem like it's going to evade
generalization
yet by combining computational
architectures which are inspired by both
advances in modern machine learning and
artificial intelligence
and deeper investigations of natural
intelligences of diverse kinds ranging
from ecological psychology and all these
other fields
that is what you pointed to in the title
conversion solutions
to the frame problem
and um
so anything else to add on predictive
processing relevance realization or
their edge before we add more in
yeah i mean there's an important point
um
which is important to both brett and
mark as well as myself
um i i i wanted to first of all try to
lay out what you might call the the
scientific provenance of what we're
talking about here but now i want to
also talk about a a domain in which it
offers
um
a significant promise
i won't go over the argument here i've
done it at all multiple places both uh
many different video series i won't even
name them that the point is
in talks i've given at conferences the
relevance realization machinery
i think you can make a very plausibly
strong case because
relevance realization is not called
calculation it's about caring it's about
what grabs your attention it's about
what calibrates your arousal it's about
what binds you adaptively to the
environment this is about the
fundamental agent arena fittedness that
makes you a cognitive agent it generates
the primary affordances that are brought
into your cognition through salience etc
what i'm trying to get at is this is
like a pro a primordial connectedness
that is constitutive of your agency and
i think
relevance realization and that kind of
connectedness and constitution of your
agency is very much
what people are seeking
when they're seeking this domain general
feature of meaning in life
it's a kind of connectedness the
language that is used is mattering being
connected
um
they're having a fit between you and the
world that you make a difference right
all of this language which is almost
always metaphorical that in fact using
the word meaning is a metaphor we're
taking something from propositions we're
trying to talk about our relatedness uh
to the environment
and i think um
the relevance realization
stop
relevance realization
when it is giving you what marlo ponte
would call an optimal grip and a met or
in fact a meta optimal grip on the
environment is actually affording that
uh meaning in life
that's one point i want to make another
point then i'm going to bring the two
points together so a bit of patience
if you take a look at how relevance
realization works and this is one of the
advantages so i've done a lot of work in
sort of insight and self-deception that
have not been gone into as much in
predictive processing
you know because everybody's doing what
has
attracted their interest and what they
find relevant to kind of phrase um
but what what i would say to you is the
very processes that make us adaptively
intelligent make us perennially
prone to self-deceptive self-destructive
behavior
because
we are intelligent
by
ignoring so much information we always
run the risk that we are actually
ignoring the information needed to solve
the problem
and
you can catch this in the evolutionary
dynamics of relevance realization when
you have an aha moment
when you go you have an insight and you
realize oh i've been i've been framing
this we'll even sometimes use that word
i've been looking at this the wrong
wrong way and we don't mean visual
perception we mean right i thought she
was angry but it turns out she's
actually afraid i've completely
misinterpreted
and you know what i'm talking about
those insight moments and that's when
the system right is is actually doing
something like punctuated equilibrium
like in evolution but the point is we
don't always have insights
we have the opposite of insight which is
we get locked into blocked into
misframing situations and
in a self-deceptive self-destructive
manner we can do this individually and
collectively echo chambering etc and
therefore we need
processes that ameliorate the
self-deception
without hamstringing
the adaptive relevance realization that
enhance insight enhance that
connectedness that's meaning in life uh
while reducing the foolishness the
self-deceptive self-destructive behavior
and i put it to you that across
time and across cultures people have
come up with ecologies and practices for
doing that and that's what i would call
wisdom it's a kind of rationally
self-transcending rationality
and
therefore there are deep connections
that can be made scientifically
plausible and empirically testable and
where some of the testing is already
occurring
uh about central aspects
of
what goes into a lot of falls under the
name i don't like this term but we don't
seem to have a better term for it
spirituality where people are primarily
sort of in an often nebulous fashion
talking about
wisdom
insight
the alteration of consciousness and and
and somehow
but if you think about it
a wise person is a person that can go
into a very messy complex situation
and somehow zero in on the relevant
information what really matters and
appropriately fit themselves to that
situation to make a difference to it in
a way
that
brings about a movement towards
flourishing for all parties involved
and so an additional thing that the
connection to relevance realization
provides that predictive processing
doesn't have i'm not saying it couldn't
have but i'm saying this just speeds it
up and makes it is
a connection to a lot of the work that
has been done
by me and others collecting relevance
realization to meaning in life altered
states of consciousness insight
flow
wisdom and that is a powerful way
to extend the explanatory
scope of the theory while also
increasing its existential and cultural
relevance
thank you very interesting there
i want to pick up
where you mentioned this may be
towards what people can be seeking with
questions around
life's meaning people search for meaning
and you use some terms there like
things that matter and you've brought up
in writing and in
conversation about asking people
questions around what matters and seeing
that as an entry point into further
investigation
as well as like connection and fit
and you also brought up from ecological
psychology
the notion of affordances capacities for
action and optimal grip where we need to
hold the sports implement
enough to use it but it has to be
flexible and adaptive and situational as
well
and this points in our language and
thought
to extensive spatial and visual visual
and physical
metaphors and figures of speech we talk
about sketching ideas and even tangible
aspects like comprehension
and
grasping ideas so we even use this kind
of optimal grip language around
cognitive ideas
and
this is being
dovetailed in a new way with cognitive
physics and the bayesian mechanics that
we'll be exploring more inactive
inference so i think that's extremely
interesting that even the formalisms
are seeing
convergence
and similarity
in terms of the
physicality of things that might seem
cognitive mental abstract even spiritual
and vice versa
and
i wanted to know where is action in this
picture
so
i mean action for me
is
the
um
uh how do i say this without i'm trying
to not say too many things all at once
there's
agent arena relationships uh set up
affordances
um and that's a basic level of
relevance realization a level i call
participatory knowing
uh where the environment the the arena
and the agent are co-shaping each other
so that affordances open up and you
don't make affordances they're not
subjective they're not in you they're
not
features of the environment they're real
relations i i say they're transactive
relations that's what affordance is and
we need to open up our ontology and this
has been a this has been sort of a
philosophical uh dimension of a lot of
this like we need to we need to bring
back the idea of real relations we've
already been implicitly assuming them
adaptivity is a
is the as the adaptivity of the great
white shark in the shark no put it in
the sahara desert it dies is it in the
ocean no if i put an elephant in the
ocean it drowns right so no no it's a
real relationship a real relation of
fittedness so we need a we need to have
an ontology of real relations and so the
participatory knowing
um is and you remember this is something
come out of philosophy that's what i'm
not i'm trying not to do too many
arguments at once you don't have to know
you know in order to know because if you
do that you get into infinite regress
and skepticism so these are things this
is a kind of knowing that you don't know
that you know because it makes all other
kinds of knowing possible for you it's a
co-shaping by the physics by the biology
right even by the culture between you
and the environment so that affordances
open up right so agent arena affordances
are there perspectival knowing is uh
layers up of recursive relevance
realization in which
the relevance is being translated as
relevance to something like working
memory and that's what salience is i put
it to you that salience is relevance to
working memory um i do not think we
should be saying that salience is a
property of objects or a subjective
phenomena um
that again doesn't ultimately make
ontological sense
um
but i i'll just keep going
perspectival knowing is knowing what
it's like to be you here now in this
state of mind in this situation and the
situation is how the arena is made
affordable to you and your state of mind
is how you are fitted to the arena but
now you are salience landscaping it
you're foregrounding and backgrounding
you're sizing up some things you're
leaving other things not as gestalted
together more penumbra right
and it's dynamic and it's flowing you're
always salience landscaping and the
function of that salience landscaping is
to select
and i mean this like in an evolutionary
sense to select which affordances are
going to be enacted
that's your perspectival knowing and
what it does when it makes that
selection is it also taps into your
procedural knowing your sets of skills
your sensory motor routines for
interacting with the viru
environment your procedural knowledge
this is your know-how this is your
knowing how
to do
and then
only
within a subset of your knowing how you
know how to make certain inferences you
know how to
uh make certain proposals and
propositions etc and that's your
propositional knowing so action is going
up that stack
that's my proposal it's the
participatory knowing that it's taking
up by perspectival knowing that is taken
up by procedural knowing that can be
reflected and extended by propositional
knowing
one other aspect of action which i saw
in the
tension or compromise between thinking
different threads
and only having one mouth
is action is like the eye of the needle
because the embodied entity is able to
only engage in one action selection at a
time with potentially serious and even
fatal consequence exactly exactly
that out that's that's important thank
you
and cognitive systems
either as if as we model them or in
their actuality can engage in
all of these interesting phenomena that
we've been exploring
like counter factuals planning um all
these different aspects that help one
emulate simulate however we want to
think about that but consider
alternate pasts and presence which is
like the
[Music]
perspective
counterfactual and alternate futures
which we must engage with to understand
which sequences of actions we prefer to
select
and then
in predictive processing the imperative
becomes to
um among other things reduce our
surprise about the world which can be an
optimistic model we're reducing surprise
about so it's not that we've expunged
pragmatic value in fact we've balanced
and as we'll explore formally soon
balanced epistemic and pragmatic value
through action selection
by way of replacing this like monolithic
reward pursuit
and seeing curiosity and epistem as
merely like a tributary to reward
exactly and so
that that's another that's that's part
of what i meant with the the analogy i
gave earlier about uh genetics and and
and uh evolutionary theory uh because
you know
and we're all familiar people
who initially encounter this say but i
don't want to reduce all surprises i
want and then
what the typical
predictive processing is oh but you'll
will sometimes go for
a short term increase in surprise for
long-term reduction and then what we're
talking about is overall rate but the
problem is you then need
something that is selecting between
different
longitudinal domains are processing um
because of course it's not always the
case that you should prefer long term
over short term right and
there's right there isn't there aren't
simple
comparative algorithms for this you need
dynamic trade-off relationships between
short-term long-term between
you know well i i like some short terms
i don't want all my short-term surprises
to go away because if if that was to go
away then i you know that would impact
greatly on my long-term learning because
i get locked in local minima and and
that's not the only explanation for
curiosity but that's that's one kind of
explanation you give and you go yeah
right but you know that means you can't
use a simple hill climbing you got to do
other things what are you doing and you
know there's you know there's people
there's people like brett and i who
think that you know there's there's
things happening in the brain like
self-organizing criticality at multiple
levels of firing
small world network organization of
multiple worlds multiple levels of
wiring that are trying to
constantly dynamically optimize these
trade-off relationships and chris honey
has talked about the fact that you can
see the brain processing at multiple
levels he actually argues and i don't
know i don't know if i completely agree
with this but you know he argues and i
knew chris was at ufc for a while
he argues that there actually isn't
memory there's just different speeds
longitudinal rates at which information
is being processed uh which is a really
cool idea um and um so
again what this does is soon as you
start to
make
those completely legitimate moves on
behalf of predictive processing
explaining things
like curiosity like
insight like wonder because wonder and
curiosity aren't the same curiosity is
there's something missing
and you
a piece of information and you go
looking to fill it in and get rid of
your ignorance wondering as you wish
when you call yourself and your world
into question in order to set yourself
onto a developmental pathway
it's an aspirational uh project and so
predictive processing when it opens up
its theoretical language in order to
address these
you can see how it starts to lean more
and more into the kind of language that
is afforded by recursive relevance
realization theory
great one
closing note um before we move to active
inference
is this question of
does the fact that these models are
reducing or bounding surprise mean i
can't have any surprise
and the nest there's as you pointed out
there's various ways to approach or
balance that
um critique
for example considering the long term or
the rate of surprise
and one of the most powerful responses
is nested modeling which could be like
the self-belief i expect and prefer to
hear from diverse and novel perspectives
then yes one will be surprised in a
little sense you know lowercase surprise
by every phoneme
but then in a deeper sense who we are
we can be connected with by hearing new
information so it's um
absolutely a valid critique of the
kernel of a single layer surprise
minimizer just like you would have
various trivial critiques of single
layer reward maximizers however
especially with nested architectures and
considering embodiness we can see how
higher level beliefs about the self
which can include like the rhetorical
and the narrative
absolutely provide a context by which
lower level surprises are
accommodated if not surfed on top of
just one thing i i i think we can make
we can even make some significant
progress and i did this in a series with
greg enriquez and christopher master
pietro the elusive eye sort of
integrating predictive processing and
relevance realization
models uh to give an account of the self
you take you know the all the
accumulating evidence that self
reference which is really just self
relevance is the glue of cognition and
perception relevance realization and
then you you you can basically integrate
that with uh howie and other people's i
think it's how we michael their uh idea
of uh a predictive processing model uh
of the self um and then they just
go together very nicely and then you can
talk about well there's relevance
realization to the self and this is not
just a homuncular thing and you can also
point out the fact that cells are
because we're mammalian primates and
this is greg's point is we learn to turn
the arrow of relevance the other way we
we are not just for our whole
development how are things relevant for
me
we also develop how am i relevant
to others and to the world and even to
my culture
and that again starts to connect up with
meaning in life how am i connected to
something bigger than myself this is the
metaphor that people use see what i mean
there's just so many things that can be
brought into a convergent and powerful
conversation once we get this
integration going i'm not saying it's
complete but i i i'm trying to at least
make it plausible that it is it has
plausible promise to extend the scope
and power of our scientific explanation
into domains that it has hitherto been
blocked from getting at
that's heavy
that's
a massive cognitive
entity that's groovy we're in the path
of least action together let us move to
active inference
so right
in the paper
you mentioned active inference one time
though i think we can see it uh
interwoven densely
and the quotation in the paper was
pointing to sajid at all 2020's paper it
has recently been argued that active
inference and free energy minimization
necessarily entail the minimization of
redundancy and the maximization of
degeneracy
first just by the way
i just wanted to highlight redundancy
and maximization just to give another
example are drawn directly from cutting
edge biology i keep wanting to show
again and again that this is not a
trivial claim of autophaises and
embodiment we are making use of
fundamental biological principles
uh this is again to give a basis for a
reply to evan's i think
everything that evan does is brilliant
right and so this is but this is a again
i just i just i i'm sorry
i take i have a deep respect for his
critique and i just want to keep
pointing out here's a possible response
great
so we have a few um
images
and pieces of information about active
inference which we will uncover through
action we will reduce our surprise about
what is under the gray box through
action but first just wanted to hear
your perspective
what is active inference how did it come
into play and when and what was it doing
in your recent paper
so um
for me and i know there's variation on
this between people i see active
inference within the predictive
processing framework because i see
the idea of the interplay between active
inference and perception and and that
first of all um
mark and brett and many of the people
that we cite
are not
bound to a strict
propositional logical or sorry the
logical manipulation of propositions
when they use the word inference
if they would do that
then evan really does have a purchase
point because then they are being
they're being locked at the
propositional level of processing
they're they're not tapping into all the
non-propositional um you know in in a
deep way uh but mark for example very
much an active embodied he says we just
use imprints because that's was the
original term and it just stayed as a
as a way of talking
so the way i think about it is like this
you have two ways of dealing with the
error you can change your model or you
can change the world um and changing
your model is broadly
perception i just want to stop here and
open that up
when we say perception we don't mean
what the empiricist gave us with the
sense of perception we don't mean just a
purely receptive bottom up taking in of
information
because we also mean prediction
right and so in a very real sense when
i'm looking around this room
i'm not detecting most of what i'm
seeing i'm predicting it now that
doesn't mean it's an illusion
true predictions are true if you don't
believe that you know you don't believe
in science
like you have to give up this sort of
empiricist thing that unless i touched
it somehow in detection it's not true
no true predictions are true they are
real relations they are true to the
world right in an important way so
i would put it to you that to get closer
to what is meant by perception we have
to take two terms that were separated in
empiricism and then put a weird
relationship through the enlightenment
we have to actually integrate
imagination and perception together you
are constantly imagine perceiving and
percepto imagining your environment but
that doesn't mean it's an illusion so
first of all that uh point
right
and that opens so much up for explaining
the the the imagination and
distinguishing imaginary from imaginal
and all kinds of important and powerful
things
the other thing you can do is you can
change the world
right and what and i take it that
active inference is a generic term for
many different species of how we can
change the world uh we can change the
world by
simply and we're constantly doing this
by the way um
we can just slightly alter our
perspective again the perspectival
knowing and you're you know and you're
constantly doing this you're constantly
just shifting your attention around so
the world is disclosing itself to you in
new ways and you right and you say well
that's just a new way of seeing it's not
just a new way of seeing
you are disclo you are look
you can't
ever see
all of one object you only see
an aspect of it no matter what you're
doing yet you think you're seeing the
whole thing because what you're doing
with this active inference is you are
tracking and i really want to play on
that sensory motor metaphor you are
tracking the through line between all of
these aspects for me that's one of the
fundamental things that active inference
means it means that i am
look look at how i'm doing and but
notice how actually you unstable how
unsurprised you are as i do this
that
is so
right active entrance is not just i make
stuff in the world it is that too you
know i get the water and i drink it and
so now i'm no longer thirsty but
it's even in the it's even in how you
are tracking which is an action a
sensory motor action how you are
tracking the through line in the
multi-aspectuality
of anything in the world because the
amount of information that any object
can present to you is actually
combinatorially explosive
for me
right and again i'm not denying the
gross motor changes in the world of
active inference but i'm most interested
in this cognitive navigation of the
multi-aspectuality
and multiple perspectives
of the world such that we find the
through line and here's the thing that's
really intriguing daniel the through
line is not itself an aspect it's not
itself a perspective it is something
that runs through them and ties them
together and that is the track i propose
to you of active inference at its most
primordial level
excellent i think that golden thread
is how
the broader system changes through time
which
we model action as influencing how
things change through time and the
causal structure of the world um but to
pull a step back
you pointed towards the two ways
that a given agent can reduce the free
energy of their generative model so this
is not gibbs free energy this isn't the
thermochemical free energy that causes
combustion this isn't tesla tech free
energy though i eagerly await the day
when that synthesis is made this is an
information theoretic quantity that
bears resemblance
to the free energy
calculations used in chemistry and
physics and other areas and we call that
bayesian mechanics and the process
theory by which it occurs being active
inference and so you point into two ways
in which a given agent can
reduce the free energy which bounds the
surprisal with a tractable heuristic
of their generative model
and those are to change the model so
change one's self and that can subsume
an entire taxonomy of cognitive types
and parameters
as modeled they don't have to be
specific anatomical region
and those
parameters that can be changing to
reduce free energy of a generative model
can include the continuum of perception
learning as well as expectation
preferences and also models of action
and the other way in which a given
entity can bound their free energy
and seek to reduce it is through taking
action in the world and so active
inference is built around the action
perception loop and it gives two meta
affordances
for
reducing the free energy
by way of minimizing surprise so i'm
going to go one more level into detail
with the active inference by revealing
the first gray box
so this is an image from
a recent paper this year by chris
thornton called an informal
reconstruction of the free energy
framework examining the conceptual
problems that arise
and the red text is a additional
annotation that we've added into this
excellent summary figure
and we can
read this figure
as being a uh perhaps a kairos based
historiography it's not a literal
chronology of history but we can see it
as part of the dialectic of research
progression and it begins with the
necessity of learning and developing
which leads one to adopt a bayesian
inferential scheme
my personal preference is that last
names don't stay attached to terms but
bayesian inference broadly just means
models that update as opposed to for
example descriptive frequentist
statistics right the necessity of
heuristics for bayesian inference comes
very early because exact base is very
hard to compute especially on large or
unknown state spaces
the necessity of heuristics takes a
further developmental stage
by the necessity of proxies that bound
the exact bayesian or even a heuristic
or approximate bayesian solution and so
we can consider that like uncertainty
reduction
and then
this is all pre-fristen at all
um here dion and uh with the bayesian
brain work and also the work of hinton
and others
in level four where we see the free
energy minimization
free energy minimization
is a computational heuristic
that is already widely in use going back
to feynman and before
to uh
bound uncertainty
with a attractable computational
approach
that includes reducing uncertainty and
kind of being on this pareto optimal
frontier of uh
not collapsing uncertainty too much or
too little
and in a way that's kind of like the
energy and the enthalpy term in the
gibbs free energy world
except we're in an informational world
now so that's where we were at before
the
recent work um in the last say 10 to 20
years
of especially carl fristen and
collaborators
and what thornton points to as some of
the key contributions that were made
was this particularly agentic
interpretation
of the lower four levels
by suggesting that the figure could be
separated from the grounds that the
generative model could be separated or
partitioned from the generative process
which is the niche
and that
entails a process theory which we call
active inference
which is suggesting a synthesis of
inference broadly considered as you
pointed to and action
and
finding all the contact points and the
ways that inference and action come
together just as the term active
inference would suggest which means like
action is used to improve inference you
turn over the object inference is about
action it's about selecting action it's
about learning the consequences of
action and how conditional they are on
world states and other hidden state
inferences and so the one level seven
that we can bring in which in the active
inference textbook is called the high
road to active inference is the
necessity of persistence and quite
simply objects that aren't acting at
least as if they're surviving will not
be around to be observed later so
whether it's a rock or whether it's a
computer or whether it's a biological
system
it must at least be acting for the time
that you're observing it or modeling it
as if it is surviving
in a potentially very complex
statistical
niche
and so these six levels um do an
excellent job of describing how general
statistical and learning frameworks like
bayesian statistics
can become
improved and elaborated upon through
computational
approaches which have only been
developed for example the bayesian graph
approach and so on in the previous
several decades
in the agentic frame
directly leads us to considerations of
active inference and understanding how
inference and self-modeling including
self-modeling about action of the agent
are a way that either we can either
think of what
agents are actually doing or at the very
least we can model what agents are doing
through active inference
excellent
i'd like to i don't know this paper uh
it looks like a paper i would like to
have uh so i'll i'll ask you to send me
a link later
awesome so then
do you want to add any more or we can go
one more level
i mean i i i think uh uh i don't know if
what i'm proposing is an a a is an
additional level maybe it is or maybe
it's a way of adding a dimension to the
highest level
uh or dimensions to all of the at least
maybe level seven six and five uh
relevance realization um and then again
we we uh relevance realization and
predictive processing have common
ancestors uh jeff hinton who of course
was at u of t uh and deep learning was
one of the explicit things we drew upon
when we were trying to talk about
relevance realization and remember the
title of the paper relevance realization
and the emerging framework in cognitive
science we were trying to say look there
are general strategies in different
areas that look remarkably similar and
they seem to be strategies for dealing
with this central problem of relevance
realization
we could see the organism's persistence
or
eco-evolutionary fitness as being like
the environment as the selector of
relevance
and then we can think the view from the
inside the psychological or even
experiential aspects of relevance to be
um a part of that broader system and we
can imagine kind of two cases one is
where the the organisms experience and
cognition around relevance is aligned
with ecologically selective fitness
yes at which case you're going to find
that entity
surviving and thriving you can also
imagine where relevance leads us askew
and things become relevant whether it's
repetitive behavior self-destructive
behavior through information filtering
all these cases in which our relevance
realization
is
missing the mark it sins with respect to
the ecological selection
exactly and that's my point how
the very process that makes you adaptive
also makes you perennially susceptible
to self-destructive self-destructive
behavior you sin you miss the mark in a
way that you can't realize you're doing
and we calibrate and we learn as long as
we
are around
right well what i meant is as long as
you're remaining in your sin that it it
itself encloses and the adaptivity
the ability of an adaptive system to
reduce reduce perturbation means when
you have these kinds of parasitic
processing going on it hijacks that
adductivity and prevents your attempts
to perturb it and break and help you
break out of the inappropriate framing
that's why you need very comprehensive
ecologies of practices in order to
cultivate wisdom it's why simply knowing
that you shouldn't do that same stupid
thing you do in your romantic
relationships is massively insufficient
for not doing that same stupid thing you
keep doing in your romantic
relationships
yes in the agentic framework
with the ecological richness that is
being brought in
helps us contextualize and take a
pluralistic approach towards the various
kinds of interventions which might be
suggested because interventions for
different kinds of relevance um
you know mal alignments self-perceived
other perceived and cases where there's
conflict there they could include like
neurochemical it could include an
action-oriented there's so many
different ways in which this nexus of
the entity engaging in inference and
action can be modified and shaped
that um without integrative models
to help us understand
it can descend into kind of a
disciplinary
preference show off
yeah yeah with the church of the level i
call it the church of the level of
analysis you believe everybody should be
working at yes
great so let's look at a second
aspect of active inference which is its
uh formal
basis
now there are many ongoing developments
in the formalisms around octave
inference and the free energy principle
and so this is barely even the tip of
the iceberg but hopefully showing these
formalisms which we explore in much
greater detail in many of the other uh
several hundred live streams that you'll
find at the active inference institute
um just to show
a few of the aspects of the formalism so
people can triangulate
and have a little bit of a sense for
where is active inference between so
this is from a paper of de costa at all
from 2020 active inference on discrete
state spaces a synthesis
so i'll make this image as large as i
can
there's two key aspects
in this figure
the top
which we won't go into detail in
is describing two types of inference
which are on the bottom perceptual
inference which is like a best fitting
estimate for perception
given the sensory data which are
incoming which includes the blind spot
and the low resolution outside of the
fovea and the lack of color vision
outside the fovean all these other
attributes of our generative model such
that we even know that we're in a
generative model and not for example
within some sort of naive signal
processing uh inward only view so i see
this as just absolute slam dunk for
predictive processing architectures
broadly that we don't experience the
blind spot we don't see it and that's
normal because our salience has been
tuned down to blurriness in that area
and so on and in the top
we have expected free energy
minimization which in contrast with the
variational free energy minimization
expected free energy is prospective it's
about selecting expect amongst
policies sequences of actions sequences
of affordances that can be expected to
result in different outcomes now the
entity could be wrong and that could
lead to the entity not existing but
within the scope of the generative model
expected free energy is how different
policies
about one's own world states about the
markov blanket here which are the set of
perceptual and active nodes that mediate
the interface between the entity and the
niche
the way that those are balanced in
prospective inference is summarized on
the top
and then it's quite interesting to look
at some of these special cases on the
bottom and so we can think about these
as like the polls
in which the big tent of active
inference is propped up on
these are cases where when one parameter
is minimized or maximized or doesn't
exist there are various special cases
that arise so just to give a few
examples
where there is no preference
we see
information gain maximization
that's like a pure novelty search
in contrast
where we have no ambiguity or risk
so we have complete information
then we can engage in classical
utility-like calculations
so that's kind of like when we don't
have to learn anything or reduce our
uncertainty
then
that's a special case in which pragmatic
value alone can be pursued where
pragmatic value has been taken off the
table because all outcomes are equal
because our preferences across them are
flat
then
the inference can move into a more
exploratory mode represented by like
optimal surprise or information
maximization
and there are some deeper and more
subtle links with maximum entropy
principles but this is just to show a
few of the kinds of formalisms that we
explore in active inference which bring
together many previous threads in
perceptional perceptual inference as
well as inference about action for
example from cybernetics control theory
and so on
just a few notes
um and then one last piece that i think
will um
hopefully connect us to thinking about
communication
culture and then also bridge to the
questions that i've seen stack up in the
live chat
so these are um from the active
inference ontology which is a project
at the active inference institute that
we've been developing for uh well over
a year now
and what we have
is a uh
what started as a terms list but
continues to develop to be much much
more and we think of active inference in
building competency and familiarity with
learning and applying active inference
in terms of quite literally skilled
performance of a language
the terms and how they're related
constitute the active inference ontology
and so two views that speak hopefully to
the directions that this can help us
pursue rigor as well as accessibility
simple
english definitions
that link to other terms just like you'd
see in a dictionary a dictionary doesn't
really tell you what the word means it
just has more words
yet it still is considered a useful
artifact by those who are learning and
applying a language and so that's
exactly what our
terms and definitions provide which are
natural language definitions for some of
these terms which often straddle the
line or confuse optimally between
everyday usages and technical usages
again surprise attention all these
different terms which you might hear
day to day being used informally
they sometimes are used both in an
informal and quite technical sense in
active inference and a second aspect
that's been a great
direction and and really inclusive area
of participation
is with translating all of those terms
into different natural languages
so here we see english as well as
equal partners with spanish portuguese
french italian russian hebrew persian
and hopefully many more to come
and so by treating this linguistic
artifact as a collaborative and
participatory project
and being able to bring in
natural languages that people have as
well as bring in computer languages like
our nomenclature and how we name
computer variables
we
aim for something like a triple play
where we can connect natural language
descriptions
of
everyday settings or of contrived
settings
those everyday natural language
descriptions can be visualized
and they can also be rendered as
executable models
because we see that as where the promise
of applying active inference can be most
powerful
when people are engaging
in the skills and in the ways that feel
natural and meaningful to them such as
in community engaging in practices
and that is supported and scaffolded in
feedback
with computational systems that
facilitate the communication
and
imagination around the discussion for
example visualization
and also provide in the same flow
executable simulations so it's not just
like there's people who are having a
conversation at the chalkboard and then
the modelers go take it into a different
room and that's where like the alchemy
happens
we think that by connecting the ontology
with
natural terms
and computational representations that
there will be new ways
to be developing certain kinds of
cognitive
models and infrastructure together
so you're actually trying to afford
wisdom
what does that mean or what does it look
like
well i mean insofar as you're helping
people to applaud sophia into promises
these are the two words for wisdom and
ancient greek sophia is your knowledge
of first principles and phromesis is how
you apply it within a particular context
so that it is effective both giving you
virtuosity and virtue you're trying to
help people translate sofia into
phronesis uh which is
the sort of meta ability that is
required for people to be genuinely wise
with virtuosity and virtue
i see a lot of
what
could be
positive for
research and technical areas which is
it's not enough to have virtuosity alone
someone could be very skilled at taking
aim
in a variety of different domains maybe
one domain maybe across domains
but without virtue
then
what
you have skill and capacity without
alignment
maybe even the propositional belief that
alignment doesn't exist or it's
impossible it's useless or worthless or
meaningless
and then all that virtuosity
to say it's for naught would be an
understatement because that person
already made that claim but it could be
worse than for not
and so
yeah and
i want to say the opposite is also the
case virtue without virtuosity
is something that undermines
uh the respect that virtue is due
because you have people
sort of
attempting virtue without having the
capacity
the virtuosity needed to genuinely
empower it in the world
and so that's also problematic
and so you can get you can get the
reduction of virtue to
following simplistic rules or merely
signaling the presence of something
without having the requisite virtuosity
to bring it reliably into being
how does what you've been working on
point towards or help us come to terms
with wise technologies
so that's
i mean
for me
i try to take
i mean a big part of my pr i wear three
hats
one is
the scientist hat which i've been mostly
wearing today
in our conversation
but i also uh i also wear a hat where i
help to
develop teach curate create cultivate
ecologies and practices
as you said pluralism i wanted to
strengthen the pluralism point you made
but i
wasn't right for me to intervene at the
time pluralism i mean
one of the things that the framework i'm
i'm proposing with brat and mark
is to
note that a lot of relevance realization
enhanced predictive processing is taking
place
by
making use
of trade-off relationships between
different values different
properties of the environment i gave you
the opponent processing with the
detention you can think of the opponent
processing within the autonomic nervous
system for constantly calibrating so
what you do is you get a system that is
two systems that are biased in opposite
directions one is trying to interpret
everything as threat and opportunity
another one is trying to interpret
everything as uh safety and uh
recuperation and they're pulling in on
each other like this constantly and
that's how your level of arousal in a
non-homuncular fashion is constantly
evolving its calibration to the world so
many examples of this uh right often in
multiple
multiple dimensions where i mean
trade-off relationships that are also in
trade-off relationships with each other
that's why i use the metaphor of an
ecology if you think of ecology as all
these checks and balances both you know
at the same level and between levels of
organization
ecology there is no panacea practice no
free lunch theorem etc etc there is no
panacea practice they right you need you
need to get a dynamic ecology of
practices
that
well optimizes
for
that
multi-layered opponent processing
and
so
i try to use
my knowledge as a scientist
to look for
places within traditional and emerging
ecologies of practices where i can see
those design principles being applied
very well or being developed very well
and then i help to develop those
cultivate them uh help build those
communities
and
then
that takes me into my third hat which i
didn't ever think i'd be wearing and i'm
wearing which is what is it to build
these communities so that
the
wisdom of individual cognition
and the wisdom of distributed cognition
are
optimally aligned
so that we have the best access within a
community and then build those
communities into communities of
communities
that's
uh this project that i now find i'm
actually engaged in a lot
i do not claim to have any particular
expertise for this it's just that i have
fallen into it and i seem to be the
person that is undertaking it so that's
why i'm sort of hesitant but i'm doing
it with other people um
and so
the answer to your question is i wear
these three hats and i try to integrate
them so that they mutually afford and
constrain each other as much as i
possibly can
very interesting a lot to
say there
uh
there's a few ways we can go i think
let's
bring up one topic and then we'll go in
the end to the uh questions so if people
have any questions please feel free to
add them now
and it's a term that's one of
my personal favorites which is oh i like
it
i like this term you introduced the i
did not know this term until our
previous conversation off camera where
you introduced this term to me which i
really liked
it's a great term arising from work on
insects and the uh work of haligan
defines stigma g as a mechanism of
indirect coordination in which the trace
left by an action in a medium stimulates
subsequent actions stigma g enables
complex coordinated activity without any
need for planning control communication
simultaneous presence or even mutual
awareness
i think it's a really fascinating and
provocative idea because a lot of times
when we hear about
collective intelligence or just
collective algorithms more broadly there
are examples like flocks of birds which
absolutely swarm and flock and they use
visual coordination but they don't leave
a trace on their aerial environment or
you have the examples of traffic jams or
of swarms or mobs of people in which
case again there's jostling there's
contact amongst entities
but a trace is not left and so those
one might think of as like a live
conversation
where no trace is recorded and that kind
of synchronous coordination is
absolutely an important component to
consider
but especially when we think about at
least two incredibly important cases
which are our digital environments and
the various modifications that we make
to them and our physical ecosystems and
the kinds of modifications that are made
to these niches
neither of those cases
are going to even be hinted at if we
only consider non-stigmatic collective
behavior and collective wisdom
and so um in some recent work with
colleagues
we've continued exploration that has
been existing since the earliest days of
wikipedia and before
around digital coordination as digital
stigmergy because although there are
times for synchronous coordination
for example in this conversation
broadly
through all kinds of modifications
including this video as an artifact that
could be re-watched or transcribed or
analyzed in the future
broadly communication
in the online setting can be said to
result in complex coordinated activity
without the need for planning control
etc etc so just wanted to hear your
thoughts on stick mercy yeah i've got
three things i want to say about that
because it's super cool
first of all uh i i for me where stigma
jury uh really called out for me is is
how it affords cultural ratcheting uh a
proposal that one of our primary
capacities for adaptivity is cultural
ratcheting which means we don't really
learn from scratch we can't we we come
in and culture has preserved previous
learning and then we ratchet it up so we
culturally ratchet
in a very powerful way and so that gives
us a kind of adaptivity that is closed
off to
most organisms there are a few species
that you could plausibly say chimps
bonobos
maybe some evidence from dolphins and
elephants uh where there's something
like a culture um uh but this now this
is where human beings excel and stigma
major seems to fit right in there
powerfully
and you wanna you wanna note
that um what we're doing right now
is so and so important because we're
actually where we're we're we are
collapsing the boundary that used to be
the
exists between live speech and writing
because we have all the spontaneity
of this
but then we it's preserved and it can
enter into this meta dialogue with other
videos where people are moving between
the videos in dialogical fashion um
until you get this layering effect
which is also working within the
cultural ratcheting and that is very
very interesting and needs to be
explored
so
that's cool and then uh
i wanted to connect what you just said
with the issue that
the neuroscientist reid montague talks
about of mutual modeling
and this is something that i think needs
to be properly integrated
into this overarching framework that's
being built um i've done some work
especially with respect to
aspects of consciousness mutual modeling
so
um
he talks about that you you faced a
certain kind of problem
um in communication um
um and it's he calls it the it's an
efficiency paradox so
the idea is well one of the things i
need to do to increase efficiency is to
reduce acting at cross purposes so i
reduce acting at cross purposes by
having two or more systems talk
more to each other they communicate more
but another way classically of course by
which i improve efficiency is i reduce
the metabolic costs or whatever the cost
of
my problem solving
and of course communication is very time
and energy expensive
uh
and so
he says notice how these and i'm doing
this on purpose are in a trade-off
relationship right the more we
communicate the more we increase our
costs and we lose efficiency
the more we reduce communication we
reduce our metabolic costs but we
increase acting at cross purposes and
our efficiency also goes down how do we
solve this and then he gives the he
gives a wonderful analogy before he
moves to the brain and he says we'll
consider an old married couple happily
married some people stay married because
they hate each other and that's the best
way they can torture each other but i'm
talking about people who stay married
because they they they are are loved
they have almost like this telepathy
with each other
and he didn't quite use this language
but he uses the language of modeling but
i think calling it generative modeling
is no imposition on him and he says
his his example is straight that's too
strong like a straight relationship i'm
just going to use that for ease of
reference i'm not prioritizing that or
making any uh cultural claim i'm just
saying it's easier to talk because i can
just quickly use common language right
so the husband
right has a generative model of his wife
and the wife has a generative model of
the husband so that they can actually
coordinate their behavior without having
to talk to each other very much so
that's where he leaves it now what i
argued is
kinda that's right but you have to cycle
because periodically they have to come
back together and talk to each other
right to make sure their model the
general models aren't getting out of
whack and then they can go off and do
their coordinated uncommunicating
behavior and they cycle and then i said
you can you can actually see the brain
doing this it you do the task focused
where you're processing all the world
and your coordinate all these different
areas of the brain are coordinated
without having to communicate much on
the task and then you go to default mode
where what are they doing well they're
all centrally hubbed and they're all
checking in with each other because you
you just do all this sort of you know uh
you know self-referential imagination
making sure all the models are in sync
and then you go back on the world
you know sync up again go back on the
world sync up again all these trade-off
relationships and how you resolve
the
the paradox and then i thought you know
mutual modeling and stigma g right like
they really belong together as
underlying concepts now montague's
argument is
you see the brain adopting this strategy
you see the brain doing this
all right where you've got areas are are
engaged in generative modeling of each
other and think how easily this could
fit into predictive processing framework
because
there's areas of the brain are
predicting other errors but the idea in
any you know you can point to evidence
of synesthesia
uh cross-modal enhancement of perception
uh the fact that one uh supposedly
specialized area like acoustics can
actually take over sight in people that
teach blind people who teach themselves
echolocation synesthesia and a whole
bunch of other things just pile up as
evidence that the brain is adopting this
strategy and so i thought
this was an interesting thing because
this notion in one sense points to
cultural ratcheting and stigma g and
mutual modeling between people but it
also points inward um to mutual modeling
within the brain and like i said i think
this is so close already to
a lot of what's going on in the
framework we're talking about they're
bringing this in and then again then we
could extend the explanation to things
like synesthesia
that you can get cross-modal enhancement
that you can have one area of the brain
supposedly dedicated to one sense
modality picking up the ability for uh
right in rehabilitation etc etc etc
well two two layers of marital stigma g
the first would be the neuroanatomical
stigma g by which local synaptic changes
and other sort of neuro architectural
changes
enable complex coordinated activity
without the need for a central neuron so
at the micro scale we have the
physicality of learning excellent and
then
there's the post-it note
and there's the note on the door there's
the modification of the environment
which is stimulating subsequent activity
and it doesn't need to be the recipe for
dinner it can just be a note or an
inside joke and so when we have a model
that's integrative and allows us to
situate advanced cognitive agents
in their niche
then we can actually bring in those
kinds of modifications which is the root
of stigma g to mark stigma
not in a taboo way but to mark the
environment
and the ways that that can elicit action
whether it's again a post-it note on the
door in the relationship or a comment on
a video these are all ways that we can
spur others to action
or and so you can just when you can take
the mutual modeling idea and then do
george herbert mead
you're right you're in a baseball you're
on a baseball team and you don't
necessarily need to form a specific
model of all the other players you might
want to have that a bit but you can he
he said what you do is you create the
generalized other you create a model uh
right will allow you to interact with
all of them very effectively and so
right we can carry around we can like
we we can have stackings we can have
more specific mutual models for how i
relate to my partner but then they are
in a right dynamic recursive
relationship with a generalized
other model uh and that also is a trace
of others like in the guts of our
cognitive modeling in a very very
powerful way
yes multi-player rituals
as cultural ratcheting
enables people to be involved in
cumulative as well as re-experienced and
reimagined cultural praxis and
if there's a level to generalize out to
perhaps it is one of them that is
relevant such that we can have
participatory ritual
as
one can say every single culture has
but taking
awareness
and wisdom into the process
of shaping
our rituals so maybe they can be aligned
with our preferences
that's exactly right and there's a whole
movement and i'm i'm involved in it uh
and i i spoke to this one at the a
recent invited lecture i gave at
cambridge about uh ritual knowing and
the connections between ritual the
imaginal and being rational um and so
very much very much uh i'll
allow me i'll give you one instance of
this
and think about how this goes to
updating and all the stuff we're talking
about in predictive processing and
reducing surprise okay so
um
you go into academics who are supposed
to be the cream of the crop
so a little bit of self-deprecation
there
and
you give them
convincing evidence
locked salt you know rigorously tight
arguments that they should start saving
for their retirement now you allow them
to raise whatever objections they have
you meet them you get them to all agree
that you've convinced them that they
should save for their retirement
you go away
you come back in six months none of them
are saving for the retirement
hyperbolic discounting et cetera et
cetera hyperbolic discounting is an
adaptive thing etc i won't go into all
of that right
but then what you do and there's
like you know hirschfield and other
people all this what you do is you now
do something else
you get them
and this is the imaginal not imaginary
you get them to imagine their future
self as a family member that they have a
responsibility for and that they love
and they want to give the best possible
life to
two things you find when you come back
six months later
the people that did the do the imagining
start to save and the more vividly they
can imagine
the more they save
so you overcome a kind of egocentric
hyperbolic discounting through an in an
imaginal
it's basically a ritual this imaginal
binding of yourself to your future self
so that you get a more adaptive
relationship
it makes me think about
variational free energy which is about
the present and the past
as religion really
and then expected free energy as pre
legare because we need to bind ourselves
to futures that haven't happened
yeah there's an asper there's there
there's other there's there's a you know
there's a current agentic
right way in which religio that's my
preferred etymological origin for
religion binding connectedness and
there's also aspirational religion and
what religion often does is try to trade
and try to find a sweet spot an optimal
relationship between current and
aspirational religio
amazing let us look at some of these
comments so any of them
feel free to add comments or give a
response so
first ali has written
in de luz's words relevance questions
are how much and how
in what cases
and who questions as opposed to what is
x
questions from difference in repetition
so what are the questions that bring us
towards relevance as opposed to
questions that
make relevance obscured
um
that's a really interesting question i'm
not
i don't know much to lose i've read a
little bit about the lose and and that's
i should read more to lose because i i'm
a deep fan of spinoza and he has a very
interesting reading i have the book by
the lewis on spinoza but um i i'm i'm
really hesitant to give much of an
answer here because i don't know de luz
very well um it doesn't have to be a
delusion answer just what kinds of
questions and and um
interrogative practices
help us find relevance
so um i think that
to collapse a large argument built from
sperber and wilson and their work on a
book entitled relevance by the way um
at least within communication
i think actually this is where i
disagree with the lose but this is why i
hesitant because i don't know to lose
well so that's my hesitancy i think all
of the questions are ways of trying to
get a reformulation of what we find
relevant they bring out there they bring
out different aspects bring in different
perspectives and point the arrow of
relevance in different direction and
what sperber and wilson
they took for they said okay
you have pr the pragmatic aspect of all
communication
what's pragmatics pragmatics is what you
convey beyond what you can say
because i can't actually put into my
words every all of the information i'm
trying to convey to you because if i if
i did that well if if and by the use of
if i'm making use of not the logical if
but the temporal and conditional if i in
this case i'm referring to me and i'm
referring to me insofar as i'm in this
current situation um
did that and that was referring to what
of all the things i've spoken of i'm
speaking of uh you know trying to uh
give give the specific uh verbal form of
everything i'm trying to convey and then
for each one of those current what do i
mean by the current you see what happens
you get a penumbra of ever expanding
attempts to to to translate the
conveyance
and you get a combinatorially explosive
list of
sentences that i can't say and you do
you do this all the time you know when
you drive up and you open your window
and you say excuse me i'm out of gas you
mean your car is out of gas you're not
trying to be more flatulent you mean gas
is actually standing for gasoline you
mean you're not completely out of gas
you have some for you can drive at least
a few more minutes
right and you know all of these things
are at work because if you violate any
one of those expectations you get pissed
off if if they say to you there's a gas
station at the corner and you drive to
the corner and the gas station has been
closed for 10 years you don't go whoa
well he told me the truth because you
right it was conveyed to you that you
could make use
of the gas station because you're out of
gas i won't go on that i'm just trying
to give an intuitive example and so
grice gives these four maxims that we
are trying to always follow
when in order to manage the conveyance
so it doesn't become combinatorially
explosive and it's the
in its manner and
uh formats and what is quality
so he gives three that are not relevance
and the fourth one is relevance
explicitly so and then sperber and
wilson just basically argue all the
other ones collapse into relevance like
uh quality is tell the truth well not no
you don't tell the truth you don't tell
everything that's in your mind when
you're speaking to somebody you select
out of all of this in there a subset
that's relevant so give the relevant
truth the relevant manner etc etc
so
we always are doing this and i think
questions actually operate right
primarily at the pragmatic level of
course they have semantic consequence
but what we're constantly doing is
asking
which
what are you conveying and what are the
implicatures
which are not the same thing as
implications what are the relevant
implicatures before i try and derive the
implications of what you're saying
that's what questions i think do
now
i want to also be clear about this that
we we need to be
directing the questions in two
directions
sometimes we are probing
are we aspectualizing framing the arena
well
in terms of is the world just so we
check to see is the world disclosing
itself to us such that we are solving
our problems and flourishing
but sometimes we also need to step back
and look at the framing itself
and ask is the framing
right actually misdirecting or
misleading me so i think
questions are always trying to
reconfigure the fittedness and one of
the things we and therefore they're
trying to enhance relevance realization
at the pragmatic level
but we should always remember to
direct the questions in at least these
two directions
thank you
all right here's a question from brock
can you give some examples of how
depending on ignoring to realize
relevance
can prevent realization of meaning
does this relate to reciprocal narrowing
and opening
yes yes totally and so brock is familiar
with my work and i'll just
um let me just quickly
uh open those the the the those final
things up so other people are aware of
what he's alluding to thank you brock
for doing that uh so the notion of
reciprocal narrowing is drawn from my
friend and colleague mark lewis who has
proposed a learning model of addiction
rather than a disease model of predict
of addiction so our current model which
governments and agencies like is that
the disease model you have this thing
it's infected you and you're trying to
like and and it's still it's
debilitating you um now
i want to make something very clear mark
is not saying that there is not a
neurochemical
layer but he's trying to well he's
trying to get an insight he's trying to
get you to realize that the disease
model makes all kinds of predictions
that have been empirically disconfirmed
i won't go through all of them but they
they have to do with the effect that you
know when we have that model
they'll tend to think of the substance
as in and of itself addictive
um you know cocaine is so addictive
heroin is so addictive well you know
yeah there was lots of
uh soldiers in vietnam using opioids
and when they came back the vast
majority of them stopped without having
to have any special treatment
they stopped using opioids
but opioids are so addictive well what's
different
because
presumably
this destruction the chemical structure
of heroin in vietnam in the united
states is the same what is different the
asian arena relationship is different
you're a soldier in a traumatic
circumstance in vietnam the united
states you're a citizen and you're not
and of course that caused all kinds of
other problems for these people because
the agent or relationships are so
different here's what mark proposes
so
i'll use alcohol because it's one people
can easily relate to
i have a very challenging arena and i'm
stressed so i take some alcohol and it
reduces the stress but it actually
limits my cognitive flexibility so my
problem-solving abilities go down so the
options available to me in the world
goes down so the world narrows as the
world narrows it becomes more stressful
to me so now i want to take more alcohol
to keep the stress away but that's now
impairing
my cognitive flexibility you see what's
happening the world as an arena is
narrowing and my capacity as an agent is
narrowing so you've got reciprocal
narrowing until i can't be any other
than i am and there is no future for me
at all
other than this moment of taking the
drug and that's addiction it's
reciprocal narrowing now i was literally
daniel i was literally at lunch with
mark lewis and i said but mark if
there's reciprocal narrowing there has
to be reciprocal opening and he went
oh you're right
and i talked about how plato talks about
this and the model of uh what's called
anagage
this model in the republic of how you
ascend out of the cave into
seeing the real world reciprocal opening
and so
um i think when we engage in
ignoring relevant information
we will often very readily fall prey to
a very powerful
kind
of reciprocal narrowing
so let's let's go back to the example i
used
you don't have the insight
you think she's angry when she's
actually afraid you don't have the
insight and so you push on her and you
only take evidence confirming
confirmation bias that she's angry in to
your model and then you only act towards
her as if she's and she's gonna start
probably
almost like a self-fulfilling prophecy
respond more and more because your anger
right you start to act towards her in a
way that gets increasingly aggressive
and you reciprocally narrow and then it
gets harder and harder for you to see
that she's not angry and it gets harder
for her not to communicate to you in a
way that you have to interpret as anger
because when she tries to give you
something else you ignore it in zero and
you have been in arguments and fights
like this at some point in your life
with somebody that you don't want to be
severed from
but that kind of thing can sever
the connectedness and when you're at the
end of your life you don't really care
how many objects you've manipulated you
don't care how many french fries you eat
you care about the relationships you had
and how deep they are and if you didn't
pay attention at that time you lost a
relationship and severed a connectedness
that enhances your meaning in life
you you fell into reciprocal narrowing
it severed a relationship and your
connectedness
mattering to another human being has
been lost
there's no more
interpersonal gravity and the
relationship does not matter
yes
all right i'm going to read just a few
uh
non-question comments and then get to a
question in these last minutes
so
griswold wrote ants hold hands in the
river of information to flow along
together
that's wonderful
ian wrote
vision infusion communities coupling and
decoupling
and imagination as allostatic
remembering of the future
ah
wow nice very cool
all right and here's one more uh
question this is from dave
so uh dave says have you found uh
oh i don't know if this is the correct
way to pronounce the name but guiles
falcionieres
uh work on mental spaces and conceptual
fusion useful in explaining and
improving the evolution of concrete
mental activities and we can also see
this work on uh generalized space and
navigation with chris fields and mike
levin and many others so whether you're
familiar with that researcher or not how
does this idea of cognitive spaces help
us work in physical and social spaces
uh for me um
again and this how you know the
connection to relevance realization and
its collection to buy connections to
biology and evolutionary modeling is
really helpful here
uh so give me a moment and then i'll uh
uh
so one of the ways in which evolution
selects is it exacts acceptation means
it doesn't have to
generate an entirely new
uh mechanism um and so let me give you a
concrete example it's one of my favorite
favorite ones what i'm doing with my
tongue right now is speaking
of course tongues did not evolve for
speech because we have so many organisms
that have tongues and they aren't
capable of speech but what does the
tongue do well it helps masticate so it
has to be highly flexible um it has to
be a poison and calorie detector so it
has to have lots of nerve endings and it
has to be it's in the air passageway
because that's how we evolved right and
so it's it's almost pre-designed as some
people say pre-adapted for speech and so
it gets exacted into speech
i think there's growing evidence uh look
at barbara taversky's book mind in
motion
that the brain
and this goes to the work of michael
anderson and to han and others
the brain is uh an exactive
process
the brain is constantly exacting
machinery that emerged for one
arena set of actions for another
specifically it looks like
the
set of abilities
that we generate
for navigating
physical space is exacted into moving
around in conceptual space the fact that
we've been calling it conceptual space
and we talk about things being higher
and lower and we move between et cetera
you can it's just it's just totally
impregnated with navigational language
and we talk about orientation and
finding our way or losing our way can
you follow this argument
what that's tracking language can you
follow this argument where is it going
to right uh you know i lost the thread
just like again and again and again and
again and and and
and so
it really and it helps explain really
weird stuff that's otherwise not well
explained
okay cerebellum more neurons than your
neocortex uh often not included in fmris
by the way which is a mistake you know
many fmris i think should be removed
from their findings because the
cerebellum is not included and we we are
now getting overwhelming evidence for
the cerebellar uh
uh cortex loop and by excluding the
cerebellum from our fmris we are conf we
are we are smuggling in a confound that
has not been properly controlled for so
just a general point there
when people are sitting in what's the
cerebellum for you know sensory motor
balance right
when people are sitting absolutely still
eyes closed
perfectly stable in meditation their
cerebellum is firing like crazy why
they're not doing anything they're not
moving they're in a position where they
can be deeply comfortable because they
are aligned with gravity and like
they're stable stable stable their eyes
are
presumably because they are navigating
and they're trying to balance complex
contingencies of attention and move
through
the experiential space in a powerful way
and the cerebellum
this this when i started talking about
this it was controversial now it's
approaching consensus position that this
is the cerebellum has been exacted for
these kinds of functions so i i think
the idea
that
um
we but that
and i'm not i'm i i've only briefly
looked at fukunier's work when i was
doing work on metaphor i didn't find it
particularly helpful for metaphor so i
didn't go into it more deeply um
but
the the idea that we are doing something
like mapping between spaces i i think
this is
i think yeah
i i think this just plugs into the
exactive nature of our cognition that it
is a form of rapid cognitive evolution
awesome well
in the final minutes
do you have any words of wisdom any
thoughts where do we go from here where
do people go from here
well it depends i mean you can go
theoretically in which you can look at
my publications and and mark uh is
coming he got an amazing grant
and other grants and uh
um and so he's coming to uft he and i
are going to do work brett and i are are
doing work uh the three of us are going
to continue to work so look for that uh
gary and i who published the paper on
relevance realization and personality
have one
pretty well written on integrating
relevance realization and attachment
theory um in terms of uh attachment is
actually um a uh
optimal gripping practice between the
child and the mother or
frequently the mother the the primary
caregiver i should say um
and so
um you can look for all of that um for
those of you who are interested more in
the wisdom stuff you can look at the
stuff i published on wisdom
um
some
i don't think i wrote any wisdom papers
on my own they're they're with other
people
uh
you if you're interested in mindfulness
i've got two publications one on a an
oxford book
uh an anthology edited by emir raz on
hypnosis and meditation and more recent
one which i recommend in the routledge
handbook on the philosophy of meditation
where i talk about all this having how
this all works out in terms of attention
and meditation and contemplation why
they're not the same thing why they're
an opponent processing relationship why
that's conducive to
insight and more systemic and systematic
insight et cetera
if you're interested in learning about
the meeting crisis you can go to my
youtube series awakening for the meeting
crisis and follow that argument all the
way through i have a new series coming
out which is about trying to
tap into how we can afford these kinds
of flowing emergent conversations that
take us beyond where we can go in an
individual cognition and empower us
and it's called after socrates where i'm
tracing out what's going on in dialectic
into the logos that's coming out uh this
year probably october november uh rebel
wisdom david fuller they're making a
documentary film about my me and my work
that's coming out also october november
of this year so that's a bunch of things
you can look for and look at
amazing well thank you very much for
joining you're always welcome to come
back we really appreciate it
thank you so much daniel and thank you
so much for uh i mean you you there's a
couple things maybe if you sent me your
slides or something from this uh that
would be great because there like
there's a couple of papers there i want
to read now and and you were you is
excellent um like it was genuinely back
and forth and um i appreciated your
insight in your perspective a lot and
also your graciousness thank you thank
you very much
thank you john until next time
thank you care thank you everyone
you